hello there reject nation greg here i
saw this rumor going around about a
certain fantastic four member that might
appear in the she-hulk series now i got
thoughts on whose rumor to play the
thing but then i also got thoughts on
why i actually don't think this is going
to happen in the series so firstly the
person who's being rumored to play
bengaram the thing is jason siegel from
how i met your mother i love that show
and of course forgetting sarah marshall
the muppets and a bunch of other movies
i love you man shout out to the movie i
love you man it's a great film i think
that jason siegel could totally do it i
feel like he could do a proper voice i
feel like even his natural voice just
maybe with a little bit more baritone a
little deeper could really pull it off
and he could provide that like solemn
dejected dry sense of humor that's very
much associated with the thing jason
siegel would actually be excellent
casting never thought of him but i think
he could actually really pull it off now
do i think that the thing will actually
appear in the she-hulk show no and the
reason why is this the fantastic four
movie recently lost their director i
believe they are still in the casting
process to flesh out the rest of the
fantastic four they do cast before we
actually hear about it maybe at sdcc we
will hear an official announcement the
main reason why i don't think we would
see the thing in here mainly out of a
hope of why i wouldn't want it to happen
is i just think it would be such a
lackluster debut for
the thing we're anticipating this
fantastic four movie we really want to
see it come to fruition we know it's
gonna come if we were to see the thing
for the first time as some like funny
cameo bit perhaps in the she-hulk show i
feel like that might be a bit of a
disappointing entrance for a character
we've waited for so long to be
introduced into the mcu like i'm aware
that the thing does cross over into the
hulk and she-hulk and such so of course
there's a scenario in which this would
totally work i still feel like right now
is the right time to do it and if ben
grimm is introduced here that would also
imply that the fantastic four has
been here in the mcu this entire time
which again i go back to i feel like it
just undercuts their solo movie their
introduction that they're supposed to
have i could very well be wrong if it
ends up happening in the show but it's
all these reasons why i am leaning
towards that this is probably not going
to happen i think they want to reserve
the fantastic four debut for the
fantastic four solo film but what do you
guys think do you think ben grim will
actually appear in here let me know